ah
[Music]
samuel
I have to ask you some questions
from here the leaders of tomorrow will come out they
are the new ones well luck you are going to
need paradise kid
hello my name is samuel I said the
waiter
[Music]
if he looks like a minister
those people are never missing  it brings nothing good
[Music]
what can you tell me about this why
we think it's about the murder weapon
I don't really
think others think we are
[Music] it
's what we hide from others
a woman is not what she seems
is that  I have nothing to confess
[Music]
I want to be an animal
and you'll never get to be with her
you hear me
when gunpowder meets fire
only one thing can happen
who was
this not a [ __ ] player
do you have any more questions
[Music]